На початку цього року президент Зеленський проголосив,
що українська армія зробить все, аби перемогти в 2023 році.
Ми вистояли. Ми не зазнали поразки.
І зробимо все, аби цього року здобути перемогу.
Пів року тому Україна почала довгоочікуваний контрнаступ,
проте здійснити бажаний прорив не вдалося.
Нещодавно головнокомандувач ЗСУ Валерій Залужний написав,
що Україна не зможе перемогти війну старими методами і старою зброєю,
і застеріг, що позиційна війна виснажить Україну.
Новий рік Україна знову зустрічає у стані війни.
Які сценарії розвитку на фронті можна очікувати у 2024-му?
Це коли жодна зі сторін не здатна здійснити прорив,
але далі зазнає втрат на фронті: як людських, так і збройних.
Це статична фаза, в якій ресурси є найважливішими,
тому що виснаження означає втрати як матеріальні, так і персональні.
У такому разі слід порівняти ресурси, які є в двох сторін.
І це не на користь України в даний момент, незважаючи на вмілу боротьбу,
особливо на нижчих рівнях бригад і підрозділів, які насправді виявляють багато ініціативи,
хоробрості і мотивації.
На думку експертів, зимову фазу обидві сторони
використають для того, щоб краще окопатися на тих позиціях,
які вони займають зараз.
Хоча й не виключають нових спроб росіян іти в наступ.
Найімовірнішим сценарієм буде просто таке собі притирання
до боїв без суттєвих проривів з українського боку,
враховуючи нинішню ситуацію в Україні.
Але є надія, що ще є достатній мобілізаційний потенціал
і достатньо волі, щоб українці й надалі стримували росіян.
Але може статися й російський прорив, наприклад, в Авдіївці.
Бо росіяни наполегливі, і ми це бачили в Бахмуті.
У них більше людей.
У них також більше артилерійських снарядів і більше техніки.
Тому не виключено, що взимку вони вестимуть наступальні дії.
Причиною стагнації на фронті експерти також вважають занадто
повільне і недостатнє постачання зброї Заходом.
Зараз очевидно, що ресурси, які отримує Україна, зменшуються.
Це означає, що Україна має критично глянути,
чи достатньо цих засобів для досягнення мети.
І якщо результат аналізу показує, що ресурсів на цей момент не вистачає,
то треба адаптувати стратегію і цілі.
Це означає, що Україна тепер вирішує -
і це чути із заяв не лише президента Зеленського,
але й генерала Залужного і генерала Сирського
- що Київ від наступальних дій переходить до захисних і спробує у наступні місяці
консолідувати зусилля для того, щоб зробити наступний крок на фронті.
Це однозначно розумне рішення.
Чому? Бо надто небезпечно ризикувати, ідучи в контрнаступ,
враховуючи ситуацію зі зниженими ресурсами.
Значно розумніше у цій фазі війни зосередитися на обороні.
Кардинальний прорив на користь України на фронті наступного року,
на думку опитаних DW експертів,
напряму залежить від підтримки Заходу.
Перший ризик - це політична воля, а також економічна здатність Заходу
надати Україні достатню підтримку.
Я не сумніваюся, що підтримка загалом триватиме.
Питання в тому, чи буде її достатньо.
Причому думати про максимально можливу збройну підтримку української армії
західні партнери України мають на роки вперед.
Усе це абсолютно потребує величезної допомоги Заходу.
Союзникам потрібно буде підтримувати Україну у цій виснажливій війні і в майбутньому.
Нам необхідна чітка стратегія на десятиліття наперед,
як перетворити ЗСУ з колишньої радянської армії на стандартні збройні сили НАТО.
Ситуацію на фронті могло б переламати надання Україні далекобійних ракет або літаків-винищувачів.
Тоді, приміром, звільнення Криму виглядало б як більш реалістична ціль.
Я вважаю, що Крим, можливо, легше буде відвоювати,
а також утримувати і контролювати політично,
ніж відвоювати всю територію Луганської і Донецької областей.
Але, звісно, українцям потрібні крилаті ракети великої дальності,
ракети, щоб атакувати тилові лінії постачання Росії.
Такі ракети потрібні також для знищення інфраструктурного обладнання,
інфраструктурних об'єктів.
Наприклад, Керченський міст можна знищити крилатими ракетами "Таурус".
По-друге, українцям теж потрібні літаки.
Тому що в них поки що надто мало ресурсів для боротьби в тилу ворога.
Також важливо, щоб Захід надав Києву усе необхідне,
щоб Україна могла захистити свій тил і інфраструктуру.
На стратегічному рівні з нинішньої точки зору перш за все необхідно дати Україні те,
що їй потрібно, щоб вона могла захистити тил.
Аби вона мала можливість захистити те, що ще існує,
критичну інфраструктуру.
Ідеться про системи протиповітряної оборони різної дальності,
середньої та великої дальності, щоб протистояти новим російським атакам.
Ще один сценарій розвитку подій -
на тлі виборів у США у 2024-му році
та втоми від війни на Заході союзники можуть тиснути на Україну,
щоб вона погодилася сісти за стіл переговорів.
Деякі "мирні" ініціативи звучали цього року
і від колишнього генсека НАТО Расмуссена,
який запропонував членство України в НАТО без окупованих територій як гарантії безпеки,
і від керівника апарату чинного генсекретаря НАТО, який заявив,
що відмова України від деяких окупованих Росією територій може бути "шляхом до миру".
Щоправда, аналітики  поки що скептично оцінюють перспективу
мирних переговорів між Україною і РФ.
Президент Росії сформулював дуже чіткі воєнні цілі РФ,
і першою ціллю є фактично знищення України,
бо він не визнає державності України.
Ця заява, а також той факт, що Україна має слабші позицій через затримки з поставками зброї,
переконує росіян, що вони от-от виграють.
Дуже сумнівно, що російська сторона,
якщо вона так вірить у свою перемогу,
готова до будь-яких переговорів.
Для цього або російська сторона має поставити під сумнів
свої воєнні цілі і буде готовою вести переговори про це.
Або ж Україна настільки ослабне, що більше не зможе продовжувати оборонятися.
Тому багато залежатиме від того,
яку підтримку Захід надасть Україні.
Якщо Росія переможе, це буде катастрофою для України, але також для Заходу,
бо це мало б жахливі наслідки для світового порядку і європейської безпеки.
Фактором, який, на думку експертів, може підштовхнути Україну до переговорів, може бути ситуація
з особовим складом війська, адже у війні країна втрачає найцінніше - людей.
Чого Захід не зможе зробити наступного року,
так це компенсувати втрати особового складу ЗСУ.
Позиція Заходу, що там досі не хочуть брати прямої участі у війні.
Ніякої ескалації - ні горизонтальної, ні вертикальної.
Тобто війни, кажучи простою мовою, між країнами НАТО та Росією не повинно бути.
Але ми розуміємо, що кадровий резерв України не безмежний,
і звичайно, демографічно Україна тут у гіршому становищі,
якщо порівнювати її з російськими людськими ресурсами.
Ще одним варіантом розвитку подій може бути те,
що експерти називають "чорним лебедем"
- тобто абсолютно несподіваний розвиток подій, який до цього перебував поза полем зору.
Це може бути, до прикладу, або смерть Путіна,
або зміна влади в РФ, приміром, шляхом перевороту.
Таке завжди існувало в історії. Це може бути політичний розвиток подій, переворот.
Цього року ми майже вже бачили таку спробу в Росії, але без тривалого впливу.
Але передбачити це заздалегідь неможливо.
Тому наразі ключовий прогноз експертів на наступний рік такий:
Попри все я вірю, що Україна здатна буде вистояти в цій війні наступного року.
Тобто якщо не буде якогось політичного рішення
і спроб покласти край війні шляхом переговорів,
я припускаю, що Україна зможе продовжувати захищатися.
Нам потрібно зробити все для того, щоб захистити незалежність
і суверенітет України, з одного боку.
З іншого боку, також шукати вихід, щоб припинити цю війну на виснаження.
Тому що виснаження в довгостроковій перспективі не на користь України.
З військової точки зору існує так звана концепція центру тяжіння.
Центр тяжіння - це область, яку ви будь-що повинні зберегти,
якщо хочете перемогти в конфлікті.
У випадку України цей центр тяжіння - передусім опора Заходу.
Якщо підтримка залишиться на відповідному рівні або буде збільшена,
тоді Україна відповідно матиме більше можливостей,
і саме це буде вирішальним у тому,
як Україна діятиме в наступні кілька місяців.
У гіршому випадку це також буде вирішальним у тому,
зможе Україна продовжувати цю війну чи ні.